in 2016 we saw the release of both Final
Fantasy 15 in the last guardian two
games ten years in the making that
proved not every game stuck in
development limbo stays there forever
now at the start of 2017 we know a bit
more about the ones missing rhyme and
learn that another former lost game
scalebound was cancelled but there are
still games that don't fit into either
category ones that were announced at e3
past and all but disappeared these are
the seven biggest missing games were
still waiting to hear more about CD
projekt red's dark futuristic RPG
cyberpunk 2077 has been a mystery for a
while now this is its third year in a
row on our missing games list years
after its 2012 announcement and one
cinematic teaser later we still know
very little about the witcher 3
developers next game we do know that CD
Projekt RED was putting all its focus on
the witcher 3 but now that its final
expansion blood and wine is out 2017
might be the year we finally hear more
about cyberpunk 2077 as of right now
we're hanging all our hopes on a very
vague 20 17 to 20 21 release window
[Music]
this is yet another game that's been on
our missing games list three years
running though it's on the cusp of
reemerging phantom dust was first
announced at e3 2014 but its initial
developer darkside Game Studios closed
down the following februari however
phantom dust is still supposed to happen
we just never got any more details about
it all we know is that it's a reboot of
the 2005 xbox game of the same name and
is coming to Xbox one and PC so if the
2017 release window is accurate we can
expect to hear more soon fan project
Allison road was set to be a spiritual
successor to PT and carried with it the
promise of mending our broken hearts
after silent Hills was cancelled its
development has been a bit of a roller
coaster it was cancelled in June but
revived in August by its creator who
formed a new studio to continue
development since I came back from the
dead we've heard nothing else about the
highly anticipated indie horror game
[Music]
Tech and cross street fighter was
announced all the way back in 2010 for
ps3 and xbox 360 before basically
vanishing producer cut to hero Hirata
assured fans in 2014 even said again in
2015 that it wasn't cancelled but in
April 2016 Hirata revealed that the
crossover fighting game was put on hold
and that publisher Bandai Namco was
waiting for the right time to release it
we just don't know when that time will
be not that we knew much about tech and
cross street fighter in the first place
[Music]
Dead Island 2 was revealed at e3 2014
with a memorable trailer and got a
spring 2015 release window of course it
missed that window and was delayed to
2016 it then lost its former developer
jager in July 2015 but publisher Deep
Silver assured us it wasn't cancelled in
March 2016 we learned that little big
planet 3 developer sumo digital took
over dead island tues development and
that's the last we heard about the
zombie survival sequel so far we know
that Dead Island 2 will have four
playable characters a player co-op in a
sunny California setting
[Music]
battle cry is a mobile like gun free
arena game with its own dedicated
developer in battle cry studios it had a
trailer and even signups for a global
beta in 2015 before dropping off the map
publisher Bethesda expressed concerns
about its quality toward the end of that
year explaining its absence from events
it's been over a year and we haven't
received an update whether positive or
negative yep this is the obligatory half
life 3 mention half life 2 episode 3 was
announced back in two thousand six but
never materialized it also wasn't
cancelled either in a recent reddit AMA
valve boss Gabe Newell said there was
still a possibility of more games in the
half-life portal universe which means
this quintessential missing game is
still floating in limbo we're hoping
2017 holds the keys to each of these
games gone missing but for now their
silence is deafening let us know in the
comments which other missing games you'd
like to see come back into the spotlight
and be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss any updates
[Music]